[Music]
users have high
expectations for the apps that are
installed on their phone or computer
and progressive web apps make it
possible for you to deliver on those
high expectations
i'm pete lepage a developer advocate on
the chrome team
i want to show you a few tips and
techniques that you can use to ensure
that you can deliver on those high
expectations
and how you can use analytics to prove
the investments that you made are paying
off
let's dive in when was the last time you
saw an app
crash because it was offline or had a
crappy connection
you probably haven't if you've installed
an app you expect it to work
at least a little bit no matter what the
network connection is like
and this is true for installed
progressive web apps as well
but let's be honest there's a lot to
think about when considering
what your offline experience should look
like
what should happen if the user tries to
start your pwa without a network
connection
what if they lose the connection midway
through
once you've figured out what the
behavior should be implementing a full
offline experience
can take time especially if you're
trying to retrofit it
into an existing code base one way to
jump start your offline experience
is to provide a custom offline fallback
page that's shown when the user is
offline or loses their network
connection
some sites like the lucas site in
germany have even put a game on their
offline page
to keep users engaged and on their site
when the network comes back
they're good to go so how do you create
a custom offline fallback page first
let's take a look at the html
for the offline page to keep things as
simple as possible
inline everything you need for the page
css
javascript any images anything all of
that stuff
should be inlined your offline page
should also be fairly simple
don't include links to other parts of
your site unless they'll work
offline and skip the links to your
social media sites
remember the user's offline so sending
them anywhere else
probably isn't going to work when the
network comes back
the page should reload automatically so
the user can continue what they were
doing
to do this listen for the online event
if it's fired
reload the page but because the online
event
isn't always accurate periodically make
a fetch request to check the network
state
if it returned to 200 reload the page
now let's take a peek at the service
worker
use the install event as an opportunity
to cache the offline page
because it's self-contained and
everything is inlined
it's the only file that needs to be
cached the fetch event handler
is where most of the magic happens but
it should only handle navigation events
there's no need for it to send the
offline page for images
css javascript xhr requests or anything
else
in fact that's why we can use the fetch
api
in our offline page to check the network
it's not a navigation event
and it's not handled by this event
handler
if it is a navigation use respond with
to try and get the page from the network
but if it fails return the offline page
from the cache
let's see it in action when i navigate
to the page for the first time
i see the service workers installed and
it has cached the offline page
now if i go offline and reload i get the
offline fallback page
in devtools i can see it periodically
making that fetch request
to check the network status and when it
does come back
the page refreshes and i'm back in
business there you have it
a quick offline fallback page the full
code with
all the comments and everything you need
to literally copy and paste it
into your pwa is on web.dev
it also includes an important
optimization to enable navigation
preload
one other thing to consider is that the
page doesn't have any analytics
so you won't be able to measure how
often your users are seeing it
for that i recommend workbox
they're recipes for comprehensive
fallbacks and
built-in plugins for offline analytics
does your app have a few common tasks
that users frequently want to jump into
for example twitter has added shortcuts
to make it easy to compose a new tweet
explore what's going on see
notifications or
send a direct message adding shortcuts
to your pwa
only requires updating your web app
manifest file by adding a new
shortcuts property for each shortcut
you'll need to provide the name
that should appear for the shortcut the
url that should be opened when the user
launches it
and optionally an array of icons
including the source
sizes and type for each icon when you're
ready to test things out
take a peek in the manifest pane of the
application panel in dev tools
to verify that everything looks right
shortcuts are one of the easiest things
that you can do to provide a more
integrated experience for your users
you can use them on android and windows
with more platforms coming in the future
there's currently no built-in mechanism
for localizing your web app manifest
if your users speak different languages
and you want to serve
a localized experience you're kind of
out of luck
but not really if you want to localize
your app name
shortcuts or icons you'll need to create
separate manifest files for each
language
for example to offer squoosh in english
and french
you'd create two separate manifest files
that part's easy enough but how do we
tell the browser
about the localized manifest file for
that
i recommend using the accept language
http header on the server to decide
which manifest to send this way
the browser will always ask for the same
file name
but will get different content depending
on the user's preferred language
to do this with firebase hosting create
a localized files directory
and drop the localized manifest files
into the appropriate language folders
then add an i18n property to the
firebase.json file
and that's it the server will serve the
appropriate file to the user
based on their preferred language
english gets the manifest from en
all and french gets the manifest from fr
all the configuration will vary for
different servers but the concept
remains the same
if you want to take this a step further
provide a language picker within your
app
that sets a cookie with the user
selection
then serve the localized manifest with
the cookie taking priority
over the accept language http header
one advantage of this implementation is
that if users change their preferred
language later
the manifest remains at the same path
and in many cases
the pwa will be automatically updated
based on the user's preferred language
to learn more about how chrome handles
changes to the manifest
and what properties will trigger an
update check out how chrome handles
updates to the web app manifest
one question i'm often asked is how you
can measure the effectiveness
of your install experience and what
methods work best
having this data is the first step to
improving your install rate
let's take a look at how we did it for
squoosh and how you can do it for your
pwa
first let's measure how often users are
shown
our custom install experience you've
seen the before install prompt event
before
it's fired when the pwa meets the
installability criteria
when this event is fired it means that
we can show our own custom install
experience
the install source variable will help us
to understand
where the install came from and how
effective each source is
it'll also tell us if the install came
from the browser
or from our custom install experience
this is especially important if there
are multiple custom install experiences
for example a button in the header some
kind of promotion that's shown
in line with other content and a button
that's shown at the end of a critical
user journey
in the before install prompt event log
the event to analytics
for consistency all of my install events
use the same category
pwa install in this case the action is
promo shown and i've set non-interaction
to true
since the event wasn't generated by a
user interaction
great so now we can measure how often
the user shown the custom install
experience
let's measure how often the user clicks
on it
and whether they complete the install
like i said earlier
we want to know where the install came
from so we'll set the install source
to header button each install element
should have its own unique id
then as usual call deferprompt.prompt
to start the install and show the
browser install dialog to the user
wait for the user to respond to that
dialog then log the event to analytics
like before the category is pwa install
but now the action is promo clicked
use the install source for the label to
identify
which custom install element the user
clicked to start the install
and set the event value to either one or
zero
depending on whether the user clicked
accept or dismiss
in analytics this will tell us what
percentage of users
completed the install for that specific
element
finally we need to listen for the app
installed event
this tells us when the pwa has been
installed
including installs from the browser if
the user has multiple tabs or windows
open
the app install event is fired in all of
them
so to prevent duplicate install events
from being logged
only log the event if the page is
visible
next check the install source did it
come from one of the elements in
our ui or from the browser
then log the event let's take a look at
the analytics for squoosh to see how
this looks
under events then top events i'll click
on
pwa install and it'll show me all the
actions for that category
i can see the number of times the custom
install experience was shown
how often one of them was clicked and
can dive down to see which element was
clicked
and how often in the case of squoosh
we only have one install button but
looking at that event value i can see
that after clicking the install button
64 percent of users went on to complete
the install
and looking at the details for the
installed action i can see what
percentage of our installs
came from our custom install experience
versus which ones came from the browser
now that you know how effective your
install experience is
you probably want to know how to
differentiate users who have installed
your pwa
versus those who are using it in a
browser tab
to measure this in sql i created a user
scoped
custom dimension called display mode
once squoosh is launched i use match
media to check the css display mode
then set the custom dimension to either
browser or standalone
this also works for safari users who
have added your pwa to their home screen
which means you don't need to use
navigator.standalone anymore
i also want to set the dimension to
standalone in the app installed event
otherwise after the install those users
would still be counted as
browser users let's take a peek at what
this looks like
in analytics i've created a custom
report
that looks at a few key behaviors for
example the number of sessions per user
average session duration events per
session
conversion rate which is how frequently
someone downloads a compressed image
and a few others next i've broken things
down
by the custom dimension i created
earlier display mode
looking at the report i can see users
who've installed scrooge
are more engaged than users who use it
in a tab
they come back to scrooge more
frequently they spend more time in the
app and
they have higher conversion rates what
counts as a conversion
in your app will be a little different
so you'll have to adjust the report to
suit your needs
but the concept is the same there you
have it
i've shown you how you can provide a
custom offline fallback page
avoiding the offline dyno and ensuring
your pwa
remains installable with the new pwa
installability criteria
that's expected to land in chrome 93.
how you can make it easier for users to
start common tasks with app shortcuts
how you can provide a localized
experience for users who've installed
your pwa
how to measure the effectiveness of your
install flow and
how you can use analytics to prove to
your boss that investing in the web
is always a win thanks for watching you
can check out these links for more
details and the actual code i used in
the examples
i'll see you soon
[Music]
you